une indemnisation spéciale pour les
harkis c'est ce que demande de julien
aubert et 32 autres députés
les républicains il exhorte emmanuel
macron à faire un geste envers ces
jeunes qui ont choisi la france pendant
la guerre d'indépendance
il rappelle qu'entre 50 milles et 70
mille d'entre eux ont été assassinés
leur demande intervient à l'occasion des
60 ans des accords d'evian ils seront
commémorés en mars prochain
on écoute la réaction de mohand hamoumou
président fondateur de agir association
justice informations réparation pour les
harkis bien sûr on ne peut que féliciter
que des députés aille dans le sens de
demande effectivement à des gestes de
reconnaissance
mais sur le fond ils se trompent se
trompe complètement et d'ailleurs sont
son texte était cohérent parce qu'à la
fois il dit que ce qu'il faut c'est
arrêter les simples gestes de solidarité
à aller vers une vraie réparation et on
ne peut pas une demande quels gestes
supplémentaires
une sorte de cadeau d'anniversaire
triste anniversaire
alors que ce qui est demandé c'est la
réparation
ce qui suppose d'abord la reconnaissance
de l'abandon
la logique elle est là les harkis ne ne
demande pas de charité ou du cadeau
d'anniversaire
il me demande simplement la vérité la
justice et qui passe par la
reconnaissance de l'abandon
l'évaluation des préjudices et la
réparation
c'est ce que nous avons demandé au
président de la république qui a été
extrêmement attentif cette demande